ok let's get into audience questions for
the week
Evan Roden says hey David what's the
most legitimate and credible criticism
of Bernie Sanders fair question so I
have no particular interest in
sugarcoating Bernie nor of making him
seem like a worse candidate than he is
I'm not sure who I'm supporting yet I've
mentioned that Bernie Sanders is in my
top three but I've not made a decision
on that so this is exactly the type of
question that I have been and will ask
myself when I think about who it is that
I want to want to ultimately support in
the Democratic primary so let's get some
of the pros out of the way in terms of
Bernie Sanders other than obviously I
find him to have the right positions on
a variety of issues he's actually
progressive on a lot of these issues on
which centrist Democrats and corporate
Democrats sort of play coy with or pay
lip service to and that is a reason that
I would be inclined to look at Bernie
Sanders seriously as the person I'd
support um I also have always had the
impression from Bernie Sanders both in
terms of how he handles himself during
speeches and interviews but the fact
that there's a record of decades where
we can see what his positions have been
on issues over time that when Bernie
says something it's his genuine
sincerely held position it's not a
position that has been calculated or
calibrated because he believes it will
appeal to someone in the possible
electorate or in his base or outside of
his base that he's trying to appeal to
of course every elected official at the
national level like Bernie Sanders does
think about how they say things and how
much they choose to talk about one issue
versus another on the basis of whether
it's useful to them for the narrative
and sort of space and lane that they
occupy
I'm not saying Bernie doesn't ever do
that but basically when I hear Bernie
say something my instinct is that he's
been being genuine and telling me that
he believes it and why and that's a
really important thing for me because I
don't want to vote for a what would the
word be like a focus group candidate
who's basically just
focus-group testing or you know putting
their finger to the wind to figure out
what's the right position to take so
those are the pros as far as Bernie
Sanders is concerned and he also has
identified some of the key meta problems
with society so money in politics
disproportionate power of the corporate
and billionaire class the health care
system as an impediment both
economically and sort of in terms of
liberty and freedom to many everyday
Americans so all that stuff are areas
where I agree with Bernie so let me now
answer the question as asked which are
what are the strongest arguments against
Bernie Sanders an area that has always
been a little bit of a question mark for
me for Bernie Sanders are some of his
foreign policy views and it's not that I
find significant disagreements with a
lot of Bernie Sanders foreign policy
views is that it's that I've not seen
him flesh out in depth foreign policy
and geopolitical ideas and analyses in
the way that he is and has been able to
do with domestic policy I would like to
see him more nuanced I would like to see
him more in-depth and I would also like
to not only see him talk about these
issues but I would like to have a
feeling that he actually understands
those issues to a greater degree than
I've seen evidenced so far does this
mean I think bernie is wrong about a
particular geopolitical issue no what
I'm saying is I don't think his
strengths are geopolitics and foreign
policy beyond some relatively
superficial statements that I've seen
him make so I think he is super strong
on domestic policy and economic policy
but the geopolitics and foreign policy
have been weaker to me does that mean I
see those as the most important issues
no in fact I think given the position
that the next president will be in of
having to help us recover from the
atrocity that is the Trump presidency I
actually do think domestic issues are of
greater importance but we've got to
rebuild our reputation abroad and you're
not going to do that without a full and
firm thorough grasp on those issues I
also think that bernie is a bit of a
victim of his own success in that his
ideas are now less unique than they were
in 2016 I know uniq is like its 0 or 1
something either is or isn't unique but
I think people know what I mean thanks
to Bernie popularizing a lot of social
socially democratic ideas you have more
candidates now that are similar to
Bernie on a lot of those issues and that
could hurt Bernie in that it would get
many voters analyzing the candidates
beyond those ideas on which Bernie now
agrees with other candidates rather than
being the lone progressive voice and
that gets us to questions like well ok
Bernie is four years older I'm not being
ageist I've seen Bernie run to catch the
subway and I've seen Bernie play
basketball and he seems to be in great
shape I'm not saying I wouldn't vote for
him because he's 77 years old I'm merely
saying in 2016 he was 75 he's now 77
turning 78 there's a history of a sort
of fresh-faced
alternative succeeding in these types of
situations you had a younger Obama
following an older Bush against an older
McCain and an older Romney in 2008 and
2012 respectively you had a younger Bill
Clinton against an older George HW Bush
and an older Ross Perot although I don't
remember exactly what Perrault's age was
at the time so there's a question not
about Bernie being white or male
specifically it's not an identity thing
it's more the idea of can you knock out
an incumbent 72 year old white guy with
the power of incumbency that he has and
the power of the bully pulpit with a 78
year old white guy whose ideas are less
unique within the Democratic slate of
candidates than they were four years ago
again I was asked to steal man the
strongest reasons not to support Bernie
these are not reasons that would make me
not support Bernie Sanders and I welcome
your thoughts what are the strongest
arguments for not voting for Bernie
Sanders today's program is sponsored in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman if
you've not already heard
Linkous it's amazing it's an app for
your phone tablet or web browser and
what they do is they take nonfiction
books popular nonfiction critically
acclaimed nonfiction they condense the
book into a 15 minute audio book you get
all the most important information and
insights from each book but you can soak
up the entire essence of the book in one
sitting
I've listened to a ton of books on
blinkin recent one is a Robert Rice's
new book the common good also bunk by
Kevin Young useful in preparing me for
the pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a David Pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a 7
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n